Ursula has a really clean line
in everything that she ever wrote.
And I admire this because one of the things it takes is
focus on what is your story really about.
So if you're writing a novel,
there's two years that are passing.
You're reading about it, doing research for it.
You learn lots of stories.
What happens to me is, well,
all these stories are so great.
I have to put them all in.
And I go into an obsessive fit.
I'm thinking that's so interesting,
I can't possibly not include it.
And so is this and so is that.
So my novels kind of like, they begin to... bulge.
As I want to tell every great story that ever occurs to me
during the two years of writing the novel.
It's something I can't control.
Ursula would know what the story needed to tell you
in order to make the maximum effect for
however long it was.
So her novels aren't very long.
And they're in proportion to how long they are because she made them as long as they needed to be.
Let me read a sentence to you...
This is a little section, just to give you a sense of it.
"It is always the Year One here.
Only the dating of every past and future year
changes each New Year's Day,
as one counts backwards or forwards
from the unitary Now.
So it was spring of the Year One in Erhenrang,
capital city of Karhide,
and I was in peril of my life, and did not know it.
I was in a parade. I walked just behind
the gossiwors and just before the king.
It was raining. Rainclouds over dark towers, rain falling in deep streets, a dark storm-beaten city of stone,
through which one vein of gold winds slowly."
It's that image you can just see it.
And I think her sentences—this comes from the very first pages of The Left Hand of Darkness—
it struck me at the time and I've never forgotten it.
I could find it very quickly
when I was putting this talk together.
Her sentences are like that line of gold
they run through the thing.
And they are a kind of living wire of thought
that you can follow when you read it.
That I think is really part of her talent as a writer.
And then of course the content: she's strange,
but she's not too strange to understand.
And she again keeps the focus on the main point.
So most of her stories have one strange thing
and everything else is more familiar to you.
So you can accept it.
That's what makes her available to so many readers
almost any reader who enjoys any kind of fiction
can actually understand Le Guin. You don't have to be
a specialist in science fiction or know
the history of science fiction. She can indeed
be your entry drug for that reason.
There's also a playfulness to her.
A playfulness and a sense of humor
even in her heaviest stories.
And maybe it's not true say of "Tehanu," but
for every one other of her novels no matter
how much she is basically a serious writer
there's a playfulness in the prose and in
the talk between the characters.
And I wanted this picture up here to kind of convey that. That's a quality in her writing, right there.
So there's something that you can only
put together as a kind of a gestalt that
has to do with intelligence and creativity.
A kind of a vision. A warmth. The warmth is important.
And I'm gonna come back to that. And it adds up to something that we often call wisdom
or greatness. I prefer the word greatness.
Because who knows what wisdom is in this world,
but the great artists have some quality that actually
as you might be able to tell from what I'm saying now
you can't quite put your finger on it.
But you know it's there when
you've read enough of that writer.
It doesn't mean that they are the finest stylists or the most poetical. In fact
that is often the surfer that's doing too many turns.
This more has to do with the content
of what she's saying.
And it doesn't have to do with being deadly serious.
I don't want to even name the writers who try to
convince you that they're important
by their deadly seriousness.
That isn't what she would do.